en Estados Unidos el comité que
Investiga el asalto al Capitolio mostró
imágenes inéditas del interior del
Congreso durante el ataque de Seguidores
de Donald Trump y aprobó de manera
unánime que el expresidente se ha citado
a comparecer ante ese panel ampliamos
desde Washington
la otan mandará nuevos sistemas de
defensa antiaérea a Ucrania ante la
escalada de la ofensiva de Rusia que
ataca población civil Incluso en la
región de kiev Mientras que el kremlin
advirtió que si Ucrania ingresa a la
organización atlántica se desatará la
tercera guerra mundial ampliamos desde
Moscú
se cumple un mes de la detención de la
joven kurdo iraní maxa Amin quien
falleció bajo custodia de la policía de
la moral la muerte de Emily ha desatado
protestas masivas contra el régimen de
Irán ampliamos desde Terán
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Estados Unidos
donde el panel del Congreso que
Investiga el asalto al Capitolio del 6
de enero de 2021 ha mostrado imágenes
inéditas del momento del ataque entre
los nuevos materiales se puede ver a la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi y orando y
pidiendo ayuda por teléfono por otro
lado el panel decidió de forma unánime
citar al expresidente Donald Trump a
comparecer ante el comité desde
Washington Cristóbal Vázquez nos amplía
con una noticia de última hora el comité
que se reúne casi que por última vez
vota para que el ex presidente Donald
Trump tenga que acudir a compartir
información sobre lo que se había de
este ataque al Capitolio 6 de enero
del año pasado esta esta es la primera
vez que se le pide al expresidente que
asista a este a estas a este tipo de
audiencias y colaboren esta
investigación que llevó a cabo el comité
de la cámara representantes que
Investiga esta situación sin embargo no
es la primera vez que se le pide el
círculo cercano del ex presidente ya han
colaborado en el pasado familiares
y sus abogados algunos de ellos también
de su círculo cercano durante el ataque
al Capitolio se conoce También en esta
audiencia además de estos vídeos
inéditos Pues que el servicio secreto
estaba al tanto de que simpatizante de
Donald Trump el 6 de enero no solamente
estaban armados sino que habían planeado
actos violentos ese día en el Capitolio
se conoció también que el presidente el
ex presidente Donald Trump pues firmó
justo después de los resultados
electorales órdenes para sacar las
tropas de Afganistán y de somalia esto
dice el comité en una Clara evidencia de
que había reconocido Al menos
internamente que iba a haber un cambio
de administración ha dicho que pues
Estos son pruebas que le van a compartir
al departamento de Justicia sin embargo
que el congreso y el comité no puede
judicializar al ex presidente
y seguimos en Estados Unidos donde los
doce miembros del Jurado recomendaron
cadena perpetua para Nicolás Cruz el
autor de la masacre en la escuela de
parkland de Florida en 2018 cruz de 24
años enfrenta 17 cargos por homicidio
tras disparar con un rifle de asalto en
un edificio de la escuela secundaria
Marjorie stongman Douglas El joven y
hace declaró culpable el año pasado de
asesinar a 14 estudiantes y tres
empleados del Centro Educativo la juez
dictará la sentencia el próximo 1 de
noviembre este proceso revivió unos
hechos traumáticos que sin embargo son
en cierto modo recurrentes en Estados
Unidos sin ir más lejos este año hubo
tiroteos masivos en Búfalo y en Ugalde a
pesar de que las motivaciones pueden ser
distintas se evidencia la facilidad de
acceso a los rifles de asalto para
analizar el tema Contamos con Maribel
Balvin de la organización
Maribel Buenas tardes En qué punto está
esta conversación que divide al país
sobre el acceso a las armas
Exacto Muy buenas tardes Pues seguimos
en la misma porque obviamente tenemos
una dificultad de conversar de convencer
a los republicanos A que pongan este
tipo de ley en camino no se hizo un
avance este año tuvimos algunas cosas
que se pudieron hacer pero más
importante que es ver cómo estas armas
no se puedan vender más que se eliminen
del mercado eso todavía nos falta tiempo
y no vemos que haya una luz clara que
nos va a llegar a poder hacer eso
mientras tanto vamos a tener como decías
continuamos teniendo Estos tipos de
masacres estas eventos horribles donde
los niños mayormente normalmente son las
víctimas de alguna forma estas personas
en se enseñan en lo que son las escuelas
los niños menores no y es en realidad
una tragedia en los Estados Unidos algo
que tenemos que resolver en algún
momento como usted misma lo decía parece
muy lejano el momento en que Estas armas
aparezcan del mercado cuál podría ser un
punto de consenso a corto plazo entre
demócratas y republicanos
la única razón sería poder que hubiera
una mayoría a bastante digamos una
mayoría que pueda llevar a cabo un voto
o sea eso representaría elegir más
demócratas al congreso y no vemos Que
asociar necesariamente algo que va a
suceder en noviembre Así que no no
tenemos muchas esperanzas rosas
desafortunadamente pero seguimos
trabajando constantemente para ver cómo
podemos lograr que Estas armas salgan de
las manos y específicamente de personas
que tengan dificultades mentales como
hemos visto con este pobre niño Cruz O
sea la combinación de los problemas
mentales con tener acceso a Estas armas
vemos las tragedias que hemos visto en
los últimos años y en relación a lo que
acaba de apuntar no A este chico Nicolás
Cruz que se ha considerado un sociópata
precisamente Más allá de unas
regulaciones sobre las armas como se
puede prevenir estos tiroteos masivos no
por como lo decía por un lado hay
personas que es un sociópatas también
hemos visto como en el caso de Búfalo
una motivación de una supremacista
blanco
en la Florida por lo menos tenemos
algunas leyes para proteger a los niños
a las escuelas tenemos mucha seguridad
tenemos todo tipo de protecciones que
hemos evitado aún aquí en el donde yo
vivo Miami esta semana un niño que llevo
una una pistola de nueve años a la
escuela y enseguida se descubrió y
enseguida se tomó acción en cuanto a eso
o sea que no tenemos incidentes de ese
tipo acá en la Florida en estos momentos
porque hemos implementado una cantidad
de regulaciones luego de parkland que
nos está ayudando a por lo menos
mantener evitar porque lo único que tú
puedes hacer es ver cómo previenes y
Tenemos muchos programas de prevención
identificar a los niños con problemas en
las escuelas para que no lleguen a
cometer este tipo de actos y rápidamente
para terminar qué opina de las
expectativas de ciertas personas
familiares de víctimas de parland que
esperaban que Nicolas Cruz fuera
condenado a muerte
muy desafortunado para ellos estamos
todavía en la televisión sigue hablando
con ellos todo el día no hay forma de
que un Jurado una vez que uno de los 12
dice que no está de acuerdo la ley no
permite que se puede llevar a cabo la
sentencia por lo tanto hubo uno que no
estuvo de acuerdo y por lo tanto no
puede haber una pena de muerte porque la
ley no lo permite él va a estar
condenado a cadena perpetua bien Maribel
balbín gracias por su tiempo y por su
análisis
nosotros cambiamos de información vamos
con noticias relacionadas con la guerra
en Ucrania kiev denunció este jueves
nuevos ataques rusos con drones en la
región de kiev y bombardeos en nikolaif
en el sur del país ante la escalada de
la ofensiva de Moscú la otan enviará
sistemas de defensa antiaérea a Ucrania
por otro lado el kremlin advirtió que el
ingreso de Ucrania a la alianza
atlántica desataría la tercera guerra
mundial nuestro corresponsal en Moscú
Xavier colas nos amplía
Rusia advertido de que si Ucrania
entrase en la ota en esto provocaría una
escalada bélica que podría desembocar en
una tercera guerra mundial así lo ha
explicado el vicesecretario del Consejo
de Seguridad de Rusia Alexander
Benedicto cuando ha comentado la
propuesta ucraniana de entrar en la otan
que se formuló Poco después de que Rusia
se anexionase cuatro territorios
ucranianos el propio Benedicto dice que
está convencido de que los países
miembros de la otan en su mayoría salvo
tal vez los bálticos se dan cuenta de
que la entrada de ucranianalidad
atlántica sería un suicidio y que por
eso las principales potencias que
integran la alianza atlántica no
apoyaron la propuesta en su momento para
Rusia los países occidentales los países
de la otan hace tiempo que están
luchando indirectamente en esta guerra
Aunque desde las capitales europeas y
desde Washington se insiste en que no
están luchando contra Rusia
cambiamos de tema en Francia un 30% de
las gasolineras tienen escasez de
combustible una falta causada por las
huelgas de los empleados de la
refinerías y de los depósitos de las
petroleras total y Epson Mobile mientras
El Ejecutivo obligó a algunos
trabajadores a volver a sus puestos de
trabajo otras empresas energéticas
francesas podrían unirse a las
movilizaciones
continuamos en Europa porque en Italia
hoy se ha constituido el nuevo
parlamento en base a los resultados de
las elecciones del pasado 25 de
septiembre unos comicios en que la
coalición de la derecha y de la extrema
derecha obtuvo mayoría absoluta por lo
que se espera que pronto la líder de la
formación post fascista hermanos de
Italia Georgia meloni asuma el cargo de
primera ministra sin embargo las
tensiones sobre la repartición de los
ministerios con sus socios de coalición
la liga de Mateo salvini y Forza Italia
de Silvio berlusconi están demorando el
acuerdo de gobierno de hecho las
disputas entre los partidos vencedores
se evidenciaron en la sesión de apertura
del senado hoy en la elección de la
adulador de Mussolini Ignacio larrusa
como presidente de la cámara desde Roma
en nuestra corresponsal Natalia Mendoza
con los detalles
fue una intensa jornada política la de
este jueves en Italia en el primer día
de legislatura el orden del día era la
elección del presidente del senado una
elección que puso al descubierto los
conflictos internos en la coalición de
las derechas una alianza formada por los
partidos hermanos de Italia de Georgia
meloni la liga de Mateo salvini y Forza
Italia el partido de Silvio berlusconi
entre estos tres líderes políticos se
lleva a cabo actualmente detrás de
bambalinas una intensa negociación por
la repartición de los ministerios del
próximo gobierno y Silvio berlusconi
tratando de hacer presión trató este
jueves de bloquear la votación del nuevo
presidente del senado dando como
directiva a sus parlamentarios que no
votaran el candidato de Georgia meloni
Ignacio larrusa sin embargo este último
fue elegido con votos Aparentemente de
la oposición en lo que es sin duda un
primer evento que muestra las
dificultades las luchas internas que
dividen a la alianza de derechas que se
prepara dirigir el país se espera que en
los próximos días Georgia melón y la
líder de hermanos de Italia reciba del
presidente italiano Sergio matarela un
mandato para formar el futuro gobierno
italiano
y cerramos esta edición en Irán porque
se cumple un mes desde la detención de
la joven kurdo iraní macza Minnie Quien
murió recordemos bajo custodia de la
policía de la moral el 16 de septiembre
desde entonces la muerte de Amin ha
desatado un movimiento masivo dentro y
fuera de Irán contra el régimen de la
República islámica nuestra corresponsal
enteran Catalina Gómez Ángel nos hace un
repaso de lo acontecido durante el
último mes
sin duda el sistema de la República
islámica no ha entendido incluso todavía
la dimensión de la indignación y de la
rabia que tuvo un gran sector de la
población especialmente joven y
especialmente mujer cuando se conoció lo
que había pasado con maxam y una joven
de 22 años que estaba de visita en
Teherán caminaba por la ciudad cuando
fue detenida por una de esas patrullas
de la moral y dos horas más tarde era
llevada con muerte cerebral al hospital
muchas de esas jóvenes que están en la
calle han sido víctimas también de esas
patrullas y saben que muchas veces
actúan de manera violenta y algunos
testigos aseguran que esta mujer fue
golpeada aunque las autoridades todavía
aseguran que ella murió como
consecuencia de una enfermedad que tuvo
en su infancia lo que crea mayor
indignación dentro de la población que
sigue protestando no solamente en
Teherán sino las grandes ciudades del
país y esto se hace especialmente
evidente en la región del kurdistán de
donde es originaria
donde la represión ha aumentado incluso
más en los últimos días se habla de
grandes enfrentamientos se habla de
patrullas de la policía yendo a sacar a
personas de sus casas explosiones y se
habla de menos 5000 detenidos solamente
en esa zona del país hoy hablaba el jefe
de la justicia iraní y decía que los
principales protagonistas de estas
movilizaciones de estos disturbios como
los llaman tenían que tener fuerte
sentencias que así se lo había ordenado
a sus jueces y que el resto de la
población que está hacia parte de ellos
tenía que ser juzgado y salir
rápidamente pero también el debate que
se ha creado en estas últimas semanas es
el velo a estas horas muchas mujeres
caminan por las calles de Teherán y de
las grandes ciudades sin velo y el uno
de los asesores del día del supremo de
la Revolución exporta vos del parlamento
alilar y Yani hablaba de que si el 50%
de las mujeres no quieren usar el velo
habría que abrir esa conversación porque
no se le pueden poner que hacer Así que
el debate está abierto falta ver que
dice la parte más radical de la
República islámica y saber cómo van a
seguir gestionando estas protestas
sigan con nosotros